he knows everybody you know everybody I
can't I can't I do you know like not
only to know Michael Jordan wants in the
most comfortable shoes and every time I
see Michael he look at your shoes y'all
Reebok are you crazy Muhammad Ali he
said you're a funny Mother Tucker you
hang out with Prince now yeah I went
over his house man because Prince have a
club in his house
went to Africa and he was like where is
Chris Tucker you were friends with
Michael Jackson right oh yeah y'all hung
out we hung out go to the movies and
Michael was so famous he had to disguise
himself and we would come downstairs I'd
be like where's Michael Michael be
covered up like I'm over here Chris I'm
here what's he like in China with Jackie
Chan he's the man Jackie on everything
BB King
he was like Hey Chris Bill Russell okay
how about Luke's TV wonder you know
Stevie Wonder I know Stevie Stevie's oh
man he called
way deeper than Stevie Wonder